[Music]
it's this week we've got
phonecase veil glittery vaginas and fish
to take your weight of neoman I like
glittery bagina delivery Felicity I like
it what a putana spa calls really vagina
Sparkle around hoes stripper [ __ ] do
and it's good it's gonna get all right
here glitter is vagina is a bad thing
isn't it when I turn that [ __ ] off T it
just looks like mother-of-pearl like
abalone shell well forever sorry there
was an Amazon a I bought that was
touched to create these phone cases
where Amazon from the jungle or the
[ __ ] company company I would why
would it be the jungle that's why I
thought so Amazonian been inventing [ __ ]
Amazonian a I bought craving phone cases
rainforest phone cases honey
how often they keep their tribe alive
give me the money but they have money to
invent any I stuff oh yeah I mean they
have that shield so you don't even know
what's going on behind I'm just going to
say there's just one person in this room
that's very uncreated who is that we all
look at them at the same time three two
one what are you looking at nobody
answers but it was using some popular
searches which we're not exactly sure
where they're getting researches from to
create these phone cases and I think
came up with them funny as results so
here we have felon cases are jokes eerie
music we got a cosmetic Botox injection
to the pretty women face cell phone
cover your so [ __ ] what so what just
makes it and then just upload it
automatic so to be sold so then that
does the work so they're just finding
commonly searched things and turning
them into phone case yeah I guess but
metal but plug with crystal cell phone
case what if it's a donor trip it's only
25 bucks I mean that's
and there's a five-star review my
grandma would like that I bought this
Comfort that's tight
yeah Lauren spoon and syringe [ __ ]
cheese we all daddy instead of table
even though titles are healthy this is
like some Olli topic this is at Amazon
and this is some Alibaba stuff
beautician hands doing I think people
will buy this [ __ ] though yeah yeah I
think I think it's so bad that it's like
you got to buy it but I get to accident
you know how like those Chinese
companies that make t-shirts they just
find random words like sexy [ __ ] spoons
right [ __ ] and then they put that on a
shirt and they sell it right I would buy
that and people don't even know what it
means in Asian countries
this is marketed towards you that's what
Americans do here with the Asian tattoos
I'm not sure no they just found commonly
searched images and they're like adult
diaper it's all diaper worn by old man
with a crutch
hey grannies need a [ __ ] hat i candy
too [ __ ] nasty no I was like looking
ready what sauce face was so close to
that whoa
I like that one that's my favorite one
it was pretty funny cuz I can see it has
a one star review so there is one person
that they actually bought it this review
is from a while back
so before anyone got all popular oh yeah
viral and and she was just complaining
how the quality was so bad she was like
I am so angry the quality is so bad that
she wants the good time this she was
happy with the design though that was
what the $1 for it would have been zero
stars of the design that would have been
me haha 23 bucks turn your phone over
what's the case well how much are phone
cases like you should like 10 clean 250
aunt range is like crazy then I got
ripped off because another one that I
got was like 10 bucks I got this for
like 30 bucks or something
look at how clean my foam beef I got no
scratches [ __ ] no scratches because my
case is really strong
and you pay five bucks right no 30 I
think that's too much man it's too many
years ago skew too much how many should
i how much money you can shoot a guy for
20
now for some friend OtterBox okay Brad
it's probably OtterBox it's spigen I
don't know okay it's a name brand yeah I
got at this print store oh not make
sense for anybody you know what though I
think it's kind of weird that they leave
a little hole here why because that's
like getting a girl shirt and leaving a
little hole in the nipple why are they
collaborating with Apple maybe that's a
lot of people like showing off the Apple
I don't I don't care
we'll get some black guest tape over
Inge all right how come yours don't have
the Apple sign mine's a card holder as
well as those a copy so if you lose that
you lose your life but I'll never lose
my phone didn't you leave it in your
cartridge now yeah but I left it in a
safe place I haven't lost my phone since
the first time I came to LA other than
that I broke them all well that's
different
fair enough damn so you lose your keys
all the time but not your phone yes good
thing your keys aren't attached to that
thing where's Mike you nervous some big
water keys yes I know so yes he's a
janitor on the weekend that's right I
actually clean all the JK offices well
how come you got it connected on this
thing right I mean you got that key
smart stuff too was this thing yeah this
is so like to remove it for valor
that's like the elementary school snack
lady key nah I do have a lot of key of
those too many
I was totally one of the the ones that
were [ __ ] in cafeteria yeah so I could
get hot cheetos every day I didn't know
that we Hot Cheetos you work in the
lunch lines and you get free food wait
for high school I was elementary middle
school and high school
what's also you work like I paid you
yeah they pay you when touch the one
that was one of the things that I got I
don't remember any student working at
the school I wouldn't have tested that
for food you just wait in the end of the
line and then you help them like cash
out and stuff oh you went to Cerritos
right
how's that for you and you would did you
go to Cerritos I went to treat us for a
year and so when you go through the
lunch line there's kids at the end or
students at the end and they're counting
the money they're kind of like the
clerks so they don't want handling all
that they would trust it with that
actually would be gone so what I use
what in Hanna yes so to them gonee or
maybe they screen the students better
and per firm of students there's a
there's like a faculty person behind
watching like every three kids Oh
because I remember there were there were
jobs like PA you can do stuff like
after-school programs you can volunteer
there like there were certain really
cheap job because I even are even are
like really upright nice students gave
away free [ __ ] just because they're
homies you don't even like like I'm not
saying we didn't do that yeah but I'm
saying I've seen a terrible person
because like it is active hot cheetos
for free you just stealing them I saw
here's what we did we got free hot
cheetos and stuff and then at the end of
the day we have to throw away with the
food that was not sold so we just put it
in this like box and put it in the
dumpster but the dumpster only had like
food that wasn't sold and it was like
not neatly in a box so at the end of it
like when everybody closed up shop after
lunch we go to sixth grade and sixth
period we don't have to experience so we
just went in there so girl I hope and if
we walked away
hold it later I still do later but that
my fellas sometimes would give it away
it depends on the day so they they throw
away on open packs or watching you I
don't [ __ ] what they do that like like
the the hot foods like the burgers and
you could buy it was like in a pack okay
but now ever since they figured that out
they're like poke holes in all of them
like oh I mean we can use that is always
the students want to eat that [ __ ] just
give it to them but then people stop
buying stuff because they realize that
we would take it and then afterwards
though it was like less and less people
also yeah I'm not really feeling I'm
comment about like in school like the
ASB because they had the hot cheetos and
nachos this [ __ ] like if you're friends
I would just walk out even ask for it
for free there's water right here I'm
like oh thanks man
I grab guys walk away I never had this
president Hot Cheetos and nachos we
could digress talking but what was our
polls about it was about phone cases but
now we're moving on to the next story so
there's this weird product is called
Hessian dust passion does
it's just crushed up ecstasy so there is
no capsule that claim that if you stick
it up your vagina you wait for it to
melt in your [ __ ] juice is glittery I
rather just get the dust and just
sprinkle it on my vagina that sounds
like some stripper [ __ ] but yeah I guess
like why would you but if you have a
glitter on your [ __ ] know if I'm going
to get freaky and you can eat it all is
it is it for that rosetta belong people
say that home like non-toxic and I guess
it is safe will show is Plato but you
want the best exactly seven there's a
lot of doctors here that have been
chiming in they're like don't put
glitter in your vagina don't put any fat
[ __ ] people does it work for the
butthole haha when you fart oh yeah I
don't like how all these it's a geared
towards women they're purposely leaving
guys out no guys want to have fun - well
the thing is this part of the Sun this
movement I know
let me let me make you a little happier
here just this website the way they
wrote about it depends there's one kind
of gynecologist was saying that she
didn't like the way they were marketing
it either because it was all about like
for him like make him happy with putting
vagina in your in your couch I mean what
a good job I did yeah that would make me
happy crazy watching a girl filter what
stops how do you put a [ __ ] inside a
[ __ ] perfection in a couch should
probably like this clean vagina
I see you can't know any men okay I put
my getting a dick and then putting a
dick ass on it crazy looks like it's
like a snake eating a snake yeah I
remember hearing that this that's the
thing like with what their foreskin over
the other penis
it's called docking listen that one I
don't know how that he's gonna feel why
did it just my that is something else
now you're sending over all the
information into the other server and
called Baal sex yeah I guess it's all
[ __ ] No so they put they posted this
meme something it says something like
when when Bay singer's me and then it
says photo and so this is something on
our Instagram I don't know if this is
the actual product it's I doubt it hey
hey what it just looked like a glitter
glue I mean I'm not gonna knock a few
hard I would never do it but it is
pretty
not so much fun looks like see you
better what I don't understand put the
pill down there oh and the freaking bus
glitter comes why why the girls think
that it's for him because we're not
gonna look at this [ __ ] I mean I don't
want a sparkly dick I'm not gonna go oh
my god that's so that's so pretty
thank you claiming that once you put it
in there he'll make your identities but
I'd be okay with strawberry Lube yeah
that's holy [ __ ] that that kind of
closet colors as I was mentioning
earlier she was just saying like why are
we promoting the fact that vaginas may
even upgrade like that they need you not
like the thing is to let you know you're
not gonna want like you're just hoping
when you're thrilled were like [ __ ]
around or something right then you go to
dinner there's glitter on your face you
know what you did okay what are you
doing I don't want glitter lipstick what
the [ __ ] for shining you [ __ ] and I know
the face is all glittery I wear makeup
it was from here it was all glittery
everybody know that I did but what you
do I think one was we the Bible bro what
you do you doubt a very fun
I guess pretty close oh no is it safe
well the company's claiming that it's
safe but then like I said these doctors
were like mmm but I thought glitter
would just brought like cut up like
wasps yeah they're claiming that it's
not made out of plastic it's made out of
glitter and gelatin and some other
things but the doctor was saying that
when you put sugar in there it'll just
create more bacteria should go give her
[ __ ] yeah it's like [ __ ] uh like
[ __ ] now what's the call bearded [ __ ]
right like yeast he feeds off the sugary
[ __ ] okay [ __ ] doing [ __ ] I think
that house maybe when I get an East
infection girl yeah Eastern infection
not that well [ __ ] dude ah you should
for our last story there is this cafe
and Melvin know that they've decided to
have their fish the fishing trip with
activated charcoal in it this is what
their fish and chips look like this all
look at a pile of pump what's in the
[ __ ] strawberry hummus no this is
that mess Lamba no not me
all right reroute blackness which is
apparently is a type of yogurt Oh beer I
tell you it but there's a lot of black
things ID but that [ __ ] look like
straight poop that's not even fish and
chips though that's what should be the
fish oh oh does curry curry looks like
diarrhea and I love that [ __ ] what a
blue with the content
this is so much punk is not black only
when I drink tap toe Bismol the only
thing you should have activated
chocolate is saucer comes and over a
justice is written swirl just as well
I'm pretty good you do have a product no
because it looks like poop that's the
only reason why yeah tips as well
doesn't look like poopoo saucer no yeah
and the thing is this is like like deep
deep black my thing is like what was the
what was the purpose of that yeah if you
as it is it make better what's the
purpose of us putting activation of the
we have a purpose for us there's a story
behind it like it makes sense for us you
know
well there's name that there's health
benefits activated charcoal like to talk
that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] because
you're deep frying the best yeah the
defeats the whole but [ __ ] you
we know what charcoal does but we're not
saying that when you eat our stuff
that's what's going to happen to you
you know what I mean it is for us so how
we came up with charcoal soft-serve so
our main chef DJ when he was a kid he
sold ice cream a long time right so he's
like stuff his face full of soft serve
and ice cream and ice cream Sanji but
you'd always get a stomachache so the
grandma would give him like activated
charcoal water to after tell been with
the stomachaches like the same stuff
that you can pet though so he would take
that and he's like oh one I just put
those two together to see what happens
and then we kind of mix that with like
chocolate with crispy rice which is
something else that we grew up with as
well and that's how you got it that's
just [ __ ] dumb I can attest to this I
usually get something cake after eating
ice cream I didn't get something eating
it me too I don't get a stomachache but
then like I get like nasty feelings but
I don't but maybe maybe that what
they're saying is if you eat this
charcoal fish your poop will look like
this maybe I like fish and chips
I'll eat it well they say that the
reason why we created this those because
when the husband of the cafe owners he
was saying that efficient ships just was
so boring it doesn't look boring it
looks amazing
bison Apolo change this make it look
like [ __ ] yeah so then when they created
this they were actually they were a
little bit worried like all what if
people don't like it what this is our
number one bestseller so people love
strawberry because they want to take
photos with intellect it's not like fish
yeah I can it's like but that's I just
like everything that I hate about food
though like I'm eating Shamu dry
Maruyama I share to you the reason why
that does well isn't because it tastes
good it's because it just looks
different young people just want to eat
something that looks nice yeah but they
don't got taste buds so it's okay
it's so [ __ ] weird like I keep like
every time I look at reviews freshness
done I want to go to people are giving
like restaurants like five stars because
they thought it was pretty it's like
what about the [ __ ] food like if you
mention the food at all I mean I agree
aesthetics should be part of it yeah
like for me it's like it should be like
a like a point or two on it you know but
at the end of the day should be about
what you're just you can be pretty
indeed like that tiny it's like it's
just [ __ ] dumb like half this [ __ ]
that I eat out there it's just it's not
good it's like what the [ __ ] you want to
just review the [ __ ] food oh no
ha but that's just me I like fish and
chips original ok Christians are pretty
fun yeah I like fish and chips I like
how it comes with peas sometimes the the
fancy and they Matthews you eat it with
a malt vinegar and whatever tartar sauce
that comes with spam lemon with Thai
sweet chili that's what I do all but
surely I sweet chili
it's like popular in New Zealand when
you heat it with a sweet chili least
that's what I did the whole time times
we chilies like put everything and you
got to go to Irish pub where the tables
sticky with beer that's how you know
it's legit good what's not you sexy
[ __ ] useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you want to follow us you could check
out all our [ __ ] link to the
description box below you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]
you
[Music]